[Music]
this is an exciting night because I got
blinded by your giant rock
congratulations let's see it I mean this
is so gorgeous so you guys supposed to
be on cloud nine congratulations now how
did this all happen
I mean I met Gigi and I fell in love
with her like immediately and then two
years later took her to Paris and asked
her to marry me and she said yes
Nats Getty and YouTube star Gigi
gorgeous
opening up to ET about their romantic
Parisian proposal at Thursday's GLAAD
Media Awards feel pressured because she
is very glamorous you had to get it
right well yeah I know I know I needed
to so it's like completely custom and
it's like has an inscription on the
inside it's like so cool I love it I
think I love it - I love it so much - no
it's custom means so much more to me it
just like it's only mine there's only
one in the world so what are the wedding
plans do you guys think you'll wait a
while you think it's gonna happen next
weekend I think everything is secret for
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]